et sur les rotules mais fait les cons
rapportent de nombreux accidents des
conditions routières très difficile
claudine soulignons dans un premier
temps cette collision frontale mortels
sur la route 132 à trois pistoles une
jeune passagère d'âge mineur a perdu la
vie la conductrice repose dans un état
critique à l'hôpital où on craint pour
sa vie dans un deuxième temps il ya le
pont de québec qui est fermée dans les
deux directions à cause d'un accident on
aura plus de détails au cours des
prochaines luttes des prochaines heures
les piétons doivent également se méfier
les trottoirs étaient glacées la
réglisse a évidemment et fallait se
méfier des branches d'arbres nous sommes
avenue papineau et bassa cécile direct
des branches d'arbres tombe carrément
sur le sol sur trois exactement
heureusement personne ne se trouvait en
dessous et un peu plus loin là bas
eh bien il ya carrément un arbre qui est
tombé sur un automobile voici donc un
résumé de cette journée avec un cocktail
météo assez particulier on glissait et
on tombait sur les trottoirs un enfer de
glace pour les piétons et pour les
automobilistes empruntaient ont maugréé
cd je me promène et plus y neige fait 8
ans moi j'ai déjà deux enfants fassent
attention le niveau de langage que des
fois j'en appelle t plus je me permets
une côte partout au québec
le même combat contre cette tempête de
verglas qui s'abat sur la province à
rimouski au préféré rester à l'intérieur
je veux rester chez nous normalement je
roule pas dans des conditions comme ça
toute la journée on a dénombré au moins
une centaine de sorties de route nous
dit la sûreté du québec peut conseiller
les gens qui n'ont pas à sortir
évidemment c'est plus prudent de rester
à la maison parce que oui le côté une
météo variées un petit peu dans leurs
droits à l'autre les aéroports de
toronto d'ottawa et de montréal n'ont
pas été épargnés des vols ont été
retardés
certains ont été carrément annulée c'est
de la misère
moi j'ai été annulés hier ce matin je
dois m'en registre est énorme en voir
les 45 minutes avec notre corps avant
puis mon vol est déjà fermée en plus de
rendre possible certains déplacements
le verglas a privé d'électricité plus de
cent mille abonnés d'hydro-québec
nous avons pas loin de cent cinquante
mille clients cent cinquante mille
foyers qui sont actuellement privés
d'électricité principalement dans les
régions de la montérégie de montréal des
laurentides et de lanaudière laval et
l'outaouais
avec tout ce verglas des automobilistes
auront besoin d'un que dead et plusieurs
piétons devront faire preuve d'agilité
en effet avec la vague de froid qui va
s'abattre sur l'est du pays dès lundi le
pire est à venir
en attendant certains prennent le temps
d'immortaliser le moment présent ici
louis philippe ouimet radio-canada morin